my name is jonathan pedro and i am a
professional icon carver
the art of icon carving finds its root
in the earliest christian catacombs and
it has a lively history from miniature
ivory carvings to monumental carvings on
buildings i am continuing this art today
and for the past 10 years my work has
been commissioned by individuals and
churches all over the world it has been
put into publications into museums and
galleries and for the past seven years i
have also been teaching this art through
the hexxamron school of liturgical art
but now with the difficulty of travel
due to covid i have been pushed i guess
to make an online version of this class
but at the same time i am excited to see
this opened up to anybody in the world
who wishes to follow me through a very
step-by-step process in learning this
art and i'm very excited to announce
that the results have been quite
astounding in fact it seems that doing
it online people being able to replay
the video over and over has really
brought out some amazing quality in some
of the
icons that i've been seeing uh happen
first time icon covers have been sending
me their pictures and i'm truly
astounded at what is coming out of this
workshop the reviews are also coming in
and people seem to be quite happy with
it malcolm soules says as a beginner
would cover who had never held a gouge i
thought the course was very well
designed and structured troy chance says
you'll be blown away at the quality and
attention to detail as jonathan guides
you step by step
taylor rademacher says the course is
much more informative for the entire
price than i was expected it is not just
learning to carve one icon and you can
literally apply this to almost anything
and in this class which lasts several
hours of video of me explaining of me
showing with different camera angles
three different cameras to try to help
you see as much as possible what are all
the different steps to carving your
first icon or to improving your carving
skills in the context of making a sacred
image i've also created a discord in
which you can discuss show your your
carvings uh ask questions to people i go
there at least once a week and love to
see what you're doing and like to react
as well i'm hoping that this class will
help to create a new generation of icon
covers which can take this art into the
future
so please join me in the rediscovery of
this ancient art